The Jumanji franchise is apparently taking
action-comedy to... well, it's right there
in the title.
The third film in the series, Jumanji: The
Next Level, has screened for critics, and
while they're not yet allowed to pen formal
reviews, many of them have taken to social
media to offer their praise.
Singled out for heaping helpings of accolades
is Kevin Hart, who spent much of the sequel
channeling Danny Glover.
If that sounds confusing, here's a little
backstory.
The 1995 classic Jumanji dealt with the plight
of two children who play a jungle-themed board
game that unleashes its hazards on the real
world as they play and who soon discover that
it's possible to get physically sucked into
the game.
The 2017 sequel Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle
expanded the original film's lore by morphing
Jumanji into a video game.
Four teens find themselves not only transported
into the game's world, but transformed into
its avatars: Dwayne Johnson's Dr. Smolder
Bravestone, Jack Black's Professor Sheldon
Oberon, Kevin Hart's Franklin "Mouse" Finbar,
and Karen Gillan's Ruby Roundhouse.
Jumanji: The Next Level finds the teens forced
to once again jump back into the game along
with one character's grandfather, played by
Danny Devito, and grandfather's friend, played
by Danny Glover.
The two old folks are involuntarily brought
along for the ride and assigned the avatars
of Bravestone and Finbar.
Critics who took to Twitter to offer up their
assessments of the flick were near-unanimous
in claiming that Jumanji: The Next Level is
absolutely a worthy sequel and Hart totally
nailing the well-known mannerisms of Glover
was roundly considered to be a highlight.
"What in the Sam Hill?"
As Sean O'Connell of CinemaBlend wrote,
"[Jumanji: The Next Level] has some huge surprises
and introduces a LOT of story that's fun to
explore.
The best reason to go back into the game?
[Kevin Hart] channeling Danny Glover.
That joke kept making me laugh long and hard!"
TV personality Tara Hitchcock concurred, writing,
"Hard 2 top [Jack Black] as a teenage girl
in the last [Jumanji] film, but [Kevin Hart]
as Danny Glover DOES IT!
Omg I could listen 2 him tell me the backstory
of wild animals all day!"
Almost slipping through the cracks in all
of the adoration for Hart was the fact that
Johnson was tasked with being similarly convincing
as DeVito in the Rock's body, and he also
came through.
"Are we dead?"
Today Show correspondent Nikki Novak wrote,
"Here's what's next level about [Jumanji:
The Next Level] [Kevin Hart] as Danny Glover.
The set pieces brilliant!
This time you really feel you are immersed
in a video game.
Danny DeVito charms and [The Rock] goes [over
the top] in channeling him.
What a blast!"
Other Twitter critics were there to dole out
praise to the entire cast.
ComicBook.com's Brandon Davis wrote,
"[Jumanji: The Next Level] is hilarious.
It's impossible to pick one cast member who
stands out above the rest.
It has some unexpected heart, too.
Big time.
Everyone is so damn funny."
The overall response was perhaps best summed
up best by TV personality Maude Garrett, who
offered pretty much the highest praise any
sequel could ask for by saying,
"[Jumanji: The Next Level] does what few sequels
can do... make a movie that's just as good,
if not better than the first.
They kept what was fun and built on it, with
hilarious changes that left me laughing out
loud often.
Worth seeing."
Fans will have to see if the rapturous response
to the flick holds up when the actual reviews
start coming in.
But so far, all signs point to Jumanji: The
Next Level being just as great a time at the
movies as Welcome to the Jungle.
The flick hits the big screen on December
13th.
"I knew it!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.